nobody knows why the Targaryen first
came to the island of Dragonstone old
Valyria was then at the height of its
power and the center of the civilized
world which ended at the Narrow Sea
Westeros was a filthy backwater with
seven kings squabbling over borders and
minor glories so much for progress the
island itself was and is nothing it had
no gold or gems to live illyrian
nobility all it has is rock mostly a
shiny black stone too brittle for war
and too sharp for building the Targaryen
scald it
dragonglass I call it useless but the
Targaryen managed to raise a castle here
simpletons claim they used ancient
Valyrian sorcery forgetting that the
Targaryen brought a small army with them
from Essos there's no magic in strong
backs though admittedly the castle is
unlike any in Westeros foreign and
strange if the Targaryen ever regretted
their barren outpost and longed for the
comforts of home the doom made their
folly permanent Valyria collapsed into
the waves and was no more to look east
was to see the ruin of their homeland
the greatest civilization before or
since but to look west as Aegon realized
was to see a fertile land right for
conquest perhaps even a new Valyria
though good for little else Dragonstone
was the perfect staging point for
Aegon's invasion of Westeros the
Blackwater Bay granted easy access to
the continent the lands there were
disputed by three kingdoms the reach the
Iron Islands and the Stormlands but
their capitals were far enough away that
none could mount a force before Aegon
got a foothold even if their kings had
been able to stop bickering over whose
problem he was
then it was too late Aegon had chosen
his first camp well with the bay to the
east the river to the south and open
fields to the north and west his army
would be impossible to take by surprise
a perfect site for an invasion and one
day his capital city King's Landing the
doom had taught the Targaryen the
prudence of Refuge after the conquest
Dragonstone became the seat of the Crown
Prince and heir to the Iron Throne
it would serve them well and me ill
three hundred years later after my
brother Robert Baratheon rebelled
against the Iron Throne and the
Lannisters slaughtered the Mad King
Aerys and his royal family Robert
dispatched me to deal with the last
surviving Tigers and children but before
I arrived a loyal Knight smuggled them
across the Narrow Sea to safety hatred
for the Targaryen blinded Robert
unjustly I was blamed and stripped of
our family's castle of storms end and
given Dragonstone in its stead over the
years whenever I demanded my rights
restored Robert would remind me of the
islands royal pedigree and pretend he
was doing me honor as if I were one of
his tavern girls to be so easily
deceived and dismissed but Robert is
dead and I Stannis Baratheon and the
rightful king of Westeros let the
usurpers and traitors sit on the Iron
Throne from Dragonstone I will be the
dagger at their throat
you